[Music]
I am excited to introduce our next
speaker as our theme has been how
systems are fueling future disruptions
and yesterday we had mark russinovich
come in as the CTO of our Azure business
to give you a view of how systems is
impacting our cloud business today we
have the CTO from our AI and research
group coming in Dave and COO David is
also the corporate vice president for
our AI core business this is the group
that powers the AI capabilities behind
Bing Cortana office and Azure it's the
group that designs develops and deploys
the Bing graph the Bing ads marketplace
the office knowledge graph and substrate
David's always been a big supporter of
research as well and our engagement with
academia he's the executive sponsor for
our relationship with Stanford and is
very engaged with a number of
communities from an entrepreneurship
standpoint and connecting high tech
communities into the Silicon Valley and
he's an all-around good guy so with that
let me introduce David Koo all right I'm
all-around good guy well good morning
I'm very excited to be here I would say
I would say in my many years of of
working in products that I had really
the deep appreciation and pleasure to
work with researchers and academia I
think we're all working in this very
advanced field of technology and
products and that collaboration I just
deeply appreciate and the fact that
Microsoft is so deeply invested in
research in academia I think it's a
blessing and I'm certainly honored to be
here and what I want to do is I want to
focus the theme on knowledge now this is
from my experience in working on in
search in advertising you know as sandy
said in office productivity Azure
there's a theme which is around the
ability to semantically model and we
just call that broadly knowledge and I
want to share a little bit of the
journey but also encourage and hopefully
frame that for
I transformations both with the business
impact and in terms of experience impact
I personally think knowledge is one of
the core capabilities and it's a rich
area for which we're still at the
beginning of understanding so I enlist
all your your creativity to help us make
advances in this area so let me start
out by just talking a little bit about
the promise of AI so there's a number
that comes up which is 1.2 trillion
that's tea with trillion with a T and
that's the estimate that IDC has of the
new incremental revenue that's going to
be created in three years with AI now to
do that and for this optimism to really
come forth there's really this belief
that there is unlocked potential in the
data assets within an enterprise or
within a company that they can bring to
bear to gain new insights and to change
the way they interact with customers and
to grow their business so that's that's
a massive massive expectation in the
context of our engagements with
enterprises that are looking to tap into
the cloud tap into AI in their desire to
transform themselves we've seen a
pattern and I want to list out the
pattern of what they're looking for in
their progression of applying in AI to
their business it starts out with
applications that are intelligent right
being able to take applications point of
point of sale specific line of business
applications productivity and make that
intelligent feedback driven predictive
analytical but be honest there's also
this desire to change use AR to change
the way that you interact with people
and that could be employees or that
could be customers and this is the wave
of conversational AI where it's not just
any set menu or interaction metaphor
it's really just this language asting
interaction metaphor and that again
we're still at the early stages of that
of exploring that trend and then there's
process transformation like being able
to understand not just analytically
retrospect
Dibley the difference between bi and a
is in some sense the ability to predict
anticipate and optimize going forward
not just looking backwards and then a
general desire that the transformation
of a company is complete when every
aspect of the system of the company is
somehow modeled that allows us to reason
optimize and to drive and so that that
wave of this value requires a company to
really deeply look at what it takes to
be an intelligent organization so let's
dig into a little bit you know you know
it's no doubt that the first step to
becoming an intelligent organization or
for a company to be effectively
embracing AI is to start with the data
start with data on silo it in many many
companies starting with product
companies but also enterprise companies
they need to start to now look at
untapping the value of your data so lots
of work in understanding the quality the
data being able to connect to all the
pulses and the inputs both in terms of
real interaction with the customers and
internal processes and interactions and
to be able to have the ability to model
and that requires us to really have a
foundation for rapid iterations
experimentation with all sorts of
different modeling techniques and so
this modeling agility with the ability
on siloed data our table stakes but when
you start looking at what it takes for a
company to truly embrace AI I would
posit that there's a third phase which
is the ability to start shifting the
mindset that data is in fact at the core
that there's a flywheel where everything
evolves around not the existing
interaction of the customers but in fact
there's a there's a knowledge there's a
model of the business from which even
software and experiences are there to
help us understand that data and model
better as opposed to the other way
around and that requires a really
fundamental thinking of what is the core
asset of a company now when you look at
all this and you say hey this seems
fairly abstract and how do we bring this
to life is this really something that
happens in practice I want to share a
little bit of the journey that we went
through at Microsoft and certainly we're
not alone so this is not saying that
this is unique but I think it is
indicative of this general understanding
and the evolution of capabilities and
mindset that is in fact changing the way
we look at the world so let's start with
being right beings a search engine web
search engine you got lots of documents
you got queries coming in in fact
there's a beautiful beautiful
interaction model of ranking feedback
through clicks from which you start
building out a richer and richer index
of the web of the documents and the
concepts within so as part of that over
the DNS as we did several years back
probably 10 years back we started
working on knowledge graph because hey
why stop it just going to links why not
bring that information start creating
that information or that action that can
be directly engaged without one hop away
right so we start building this
knowledge graph it turns out to be a
pretty big graph two billion plus
entities continues to evolve across
different domains it's open domain many
many web pages lots of techniques on it
but the thing that is interesting is
around a couple of years ago we start
shifting it from oh this that's just
that's just a Bing graph that's just the
Bing graph it's only useful for being
and we realize that what underlies it is
in fact a model of the digital world
right these are the people places and
things that happen on the web these are
digital artifacts on celebrities people
on locations stores and when you look at
it from that standpoint we're starting
to now create understand both the facets
the relationships of things in the world
the public world right and we can start
joining with structured data and as a
result that piece of asset that piece of
asset created a life of its own
it's now valuable not just in Bing but
it's valuable whenever you need a model
of the world which could be an office
which would be in cloud and that's
something we're seeing this general
pattern that you start out with an
application feedback but you start
creating valuable assets and knowledge
models
that have life beyond that scenario and
let's go into the next one so a little
bit later my colleague Krantz on will
come and talk a little bit about the
Microsoft academic graph and this one
think of it as this is a graph that
models research and technology
innovations and really that process of
who communicates and what published what
collaboration from what institution and
where does the flow of new ideas start
to now come up from the minds of people
into a broader adoption and inspiring
whole fields and domains and that's an
another example where you can now use
that aggregator signal for many many
different places the publication's the
fields of studies and start to create
that ontology that gives you a
predictive power on the impact of new
articles or new fields is that a hot
field is that going to be in traction
these are really that model that now
takes a life of its own that you can now
extend to other areas and in fact it's
not just the public domain it's also in
enterprises so in the case of office you
would say hey office it's just a bunch
of word out Outlook email SharePoint but
in fact how look is in fact at this core
of how people in a company interact and
communicate and collaborate so that flow
of signal allows us to start creating a
model digital work how collaboration
happens on the on what topic
how does people and organization impact
that how do we now understand the
activities that people do how do we now
understand in fact the topics and the
customers and the interactions to
predict the effectiveness of engagements
with companies collaboration across
teams the likelihood of information
progress that are usually scattered in
unstructured way so we have massive
systems where we've taken in some sense
that journey from being and our
technology understanding of and the
modeling capabilities and we brought it
to office right and we're still at the
beginning of this journey but this is a
case where now we're saying hey maybe
maybe office is in fact representing a
deeper understanding of how work is done
digital work and can that create more
dhilae for experiences but
so can that now be bolstered to help
companies transform and in the way that
they interact with their employees and
customers so these are just examples
where knowledge starts out from hey
let's make an application smarter to
starting to create data assets that can
now inspire and connect to new scenarios
now once you have knowledge doesn't mean
that it's readily accessible by people
right knowledge is semantically
organized and understandable but humans
ability to interact and engage and to
conflate is in fact unstructured right
so let's take for example search and
question Q&A you can ask in any natural
language anything but you have to
somehow map it to what's known and
modeled in a knowledge well that could
require technology Parrikar's
understanding both how the model
language but also the information of
knowledge within you can also look at
enrichment recommendations the
relatedness of concepts so that you can
start to now connect the dots right in
the world view that we have at Microsoft
that Satya talked about which is this
intelligent cloud intelligent edge we
talked about this ability to connect the
dots so it's not just disparate
interactions with different devices it's
a multi device multi-sensory coordinated
world and that coordination that glue is
in fact that connective fabric of people
of things of the environments of the
context that is the glue that starts to
tie that different pieces together into
something coherent so I want to now give
some examples of the power of these
experiences when you have knowledge and
this is in fact the thing that gets is
excited but again we're at the early
stages of it so let's start with nice
animation let's go with the Bing
starting with Bing clearly we have the
ability to have reasonable and
interesting questions around the
knowledge graph so in this case what's
the size of Ritalin there's the
knowledge graph there are different
nodes there different facets based on
that we can now derive the computations
to answer that in a much more directed
fashion right these you can imagine this
across a large number of domains but
we've also recognized that that doesn't
capture all the information
there's still lots of information in the
billions and billions of documents that
may not be explicitly represented and so
there's lots of advances in machine
reading comprehension new modeling deep
Q&A and these are things that we have in
being and also in the malapa as well as
many many academia and research systems
that are out there and this is the
casework now we understand semantically
model the knowledge is within snippets
different documents warranties and be
able to now have QA around it and in
fact we've taken it one step further and
say it's not just one answer in fact
there are different perspectives because
when you start looking at information it
is not the facts only it is opinions its
perspectives and the ability to surface
that and to recognize that there's also
critical so we have this multi
perspective answers now these are just
examples that now go beyond the ranking
of the temple links to now understanding
what is the inherent intent and the need
that people may have and how do we start
to surface technologists within the web
and a lot of that requires this too now
investing technologies that now to
elevate and goes beyond the indexing the
posting lists and to start to look at
the organization of information and to
be able to reason around it now in
office it turns out we're also starting
to now bring that technology and that
knowledge infusion into the experiences
that you all know like word so in this
case imagine you're writing some article
you're writing a paper and you want to
know hey I got to be inspired or tell me
a little bit of contextual information
so in this case where we're
systematically bringing what's available
on the web from the knowledge graph from
internal the company to now be
contextually relevant to the things
that's happening in your workspace in
the thing that you're currently working
on so again it's a different way of
bringing in that connected tissue of
context that we think allows you to stay
in the flow if you look at productivity
in one way to define productivity is
staying in the flow where your most
productive as long as you can and bring
that contextual knowledge in a relevant
integrated way to anticipate that next
step is in fact Oh
mark of good knowledge capabilities and
in fact it doesn't even stop at the word
or the flow imagine you're in Excel you
got lots of different ways of describing
data and values and in fact that there's
information there are referenced that
may be valuable for you to contextualize
so in this case for example you can
imagine that let's say you have the word
United but appears in different contexts
is and this is just to illustrate the
complexity and the richness of the
language but also the ambiguity so in
this case United in the last context is
in fact a bunch of movies right but we
wouldn't know that unless we actually
understood the other elements be able to
conflate and likewise in other contexts
is it could be an airline it could be
companies it could be European football
clubs I mean it could be many many
different ways but again context matters
and the ability to model that is in fact
rich and so we're only beginning to
scratch the surface of bringing
information and knowledge in the context
of user needs in context or through
explicit queries and intent but even
beyond this the one thing that we've
discovered as we start working on agents
and assistants and BOTS is that whereas
knowledge may be considered to be
valuable but it's still a nice to have
you can still get your work done with
temporal links it can still get your
word document done without being
inspired by contextual search but
indicates the conversations especially
conversations that go multi-turn you
kind of need knowledge and the reason is
the context and the information
interactions that you have in one turn
needs to be passed and transferred to
the next one so that you can start to
reason and that fluidness and that
sharing of context across turns where
the turns and the actions taken on each
term may be from different vendors
different applications and different
knowledge bases is in fact one of the
hallmark challenges and opportunities in
conversation design so in this case
imagine that you're now going through
this this dis flow in fact I'm this is
inspired by our semantic Machines
acquisition we were very excited to get
Dan Klein and Percy to be part of our
family but in this case imagine you say
hey I want to go to
two days before Thanksgiving what is two
days before Thanksgiving what does it
mean on new york we're at the airport's
how do I understand it how do I
reflected how do I understand the facets
for elaboration these are all things
that you would say yeah it actually
requires you to orchestrate across many
many back-end systems and api's each one
has an ontology in some sense of the
values of the capabilities and so in
this case it's really about this ability
use knowledge to connect connect the
dots across turns to be able to reason
and contextualize and to guide that
discussion and so in this case take
travel in New York be able to now
recognize that nearby airports of New
York are JFK and the certain location
likewise you cannot imagine each of the
api's and each of the systems having its
own variant we need to learn the
Association and kind of do dynamic
conflation across these now with all the
things said with knowledge there are
many things you can do to start to now
bring that knowledge in the context of
interactions and flows but how do we
bring this to life and in this is a rich
area of research and product efforts and
so I'm not going to go through the
details on this because I think you're
all kind of world experts but I do want
to share a little bit of how we're
looking at the dimensions of what
knowledge systems the quality what does
that mean and also some of the
challenges that we have that we think
are really pushing us to the limit but
certainly an area that we like to invite
your creativity and your collaboration
so in this case to bring knowledge
systems to life we start with the fact
that hey data can be chaotic inga come
from structured and unstructured right
lots of effort across different pieces
but bringing that together in some
coherent knowledge production process to
be something where as fresh highly
structured semantically understand but
that's a challenge that's kind of the
data chaos to the structured semantics
flow and there are different approaches
not that one approach is better but in
fact over
a number of these will work in concert
right starting with people you have
Wikipedia dbpedia like there are certain
efforts that really do require the
domain experts to start capturing that
knowledge in some descent of away and to
be able to now create an incentive that
keeps it fresh right quick Abita is the
great example almost every search engine
kind of looks at Wikipedia and say
that's great let's use that to see it
our understanding because that's
probably the you know the best
articulation of the basic shareable
knowledge that people interact and
that's one of the facets that I think
it's important for knowledge it's not
just important for systems to understand
it is something that needs to be
understandable and explainable to people
right but beyond knowledge people at
some point you're gonna run out of steam
because at some point either the
willingness or the capacity of people
are gonna hit a limit and so this is
where systems start to come in so this
this theme of systems for AI and AI
systems it's in fact one of the
hallmarks where I think it applies
beautifully to knowledge systems so in
this case we can imagine implicit
modeling we talked about the Machine
reading comprehension we're still at the
early stages of it but again this is a
case where we're now trying to
understand the shape to the language the
shape of information and the shape of
the retrieval so lots of efforts on that
but there's also knowledge
representation representation that are
explicit these are the triplets these
are the RDF these are the different
graph structures and they're I would say
we have lots of lots of research and
lots of production systems being Google
Facebook LinkedIn they are all the
systems that are creating these
knowledge representations some which are
proprietary some of which are public and
in fact a lot of research systems psyche
from the early days all the way to the
research systems that exist today so
this is an active area now what I want
to do is is just talk a little bit about
regardless of the approach there are
different dimensions that we evaluate
and assess knowledge right is a
knowledge system correct
like what's the degree of correctness
what's the degree of freshness
what's the dealer coverage there's a
standard but when you start looking at
it they
kind of work against each other when you
hit extreme scale in fact that's where
we end up which is it all sounds good
for 1 million documents it sounds good
for 10 million it works really hard if
you have hundreds of billion and and
that's kind of the chaotic web and it's
not just accurate chaotic web it's
chaotic enterprise systems and kind of
real-life situations so with that let me
just give some some examples in the case
of correctness precision really does
matter right because once you create
that knowledge you have to stand by the
quality if something is wrong you can't
just point to the source and say well I
don't know I think I extracted it right
this is fake news it's fake knowledge
bad well you got to look at Authority
you got to look at Authority you got to
look at the synthesis how do I look at
voting if I don't have an authority how
do I judge how do I get user feedback
that's a challenge especially when you
have uncork astray 'td multi-party
sources of information freshness speed
matters right things are constantly
changing in many cases we don't even
know what changed not to even mention
the ability to propagate that update
through the system in a way where we
understand that some of the updates may
in fact be incorrect so you can actually
start propagating lots of challenges
with one mistake you can ripple and
destroy pretty much everything and
that's the lesson we have and and then
coverage right size really does matter
at some point they'll say great this all
sounds good but is it complete does it
capture that domain so all these work in
different forces and there are lots of
systems and lots of efforts there are in
fact at the frontier of this I want to
list out at some of these to both
acknowledge that lots of problems still
remain unsolved but also the importance
of these problems for us to get ahead in
this in this world where I think
knowledge is increasingly important
right unsupervised unsupervised
autonomous these are all keywords
basically we say we can't play humans
and depend on humans to do the final
verification in all the cases right how
do i unstruck sure when I look at a
webpage it's not just the head sites
that I can create templates and do rapid
induction
site understanding like can I understand
the unstructured nature of information
can I understand and cluster can I
extract facts can I test our hypothesis
through verification and validation like
that's that's a whole body of work that
pushes from the head to in fact that
torso tell knowledge in somatic
embedding right you got lots of today
explicit knowledge that's present today
through years and decades of human
aggregation or capabilities aggregation
and yet we're building neural networks
and how do we see that how do we anchor
that knowledge so that you build upon it
as opposed to restart from scratch and
I'll just pick another one like
multilingual right language
fundamentally is multilingual in fact
information on knowledge may in fact be
multilingual and multicultural and how
do you even represent that in a way in
which you don't get to precise because
once you get to precise you get to
brittle and there's no generalization
all the way to you're overly bucketing
things and you're like it's not that
useful all right so these are lots of
active research both within technology
product companies in research as well as
in academia and I encourage continuing
innovation we will look to partner in
any and all of these but let's share a
little bit of our learnings like there
are many things we did throughout all
the systems that you heard about but
I'll just pick a couple that I think are
really hard problems and we've taken
steps towards but I think it's not a
problem that's gonna easily be solved
but I'll just use that hopefully to tee
up the areas where I think there's
productive research to be done one is
the inherent complexity of the real
world we talked a little bit about it I
will share some of the learnings that we
had you know dressing that the second is
this symbolic versus neural approach
where you can get the best of both
worlds both the ability to now explore
but also anchor on the knowledge that
exists and the ability to make it an
understandable explainable and the last
one in fact is something that we're
seeing a huge swell of interest which is
how enterprises can start to take
control to understand their unstructured
there are digital information assets in
a way that makes it available for them
to change the way they interact with
customers employees right so I'll just
list out some of you each one has his
own challenges we've made some progress
for it but I wouldn't say that we've
kind of cracked a nut so let's start
with the inherent complexity right just
to motivate this a little bit I working
in web search is beautiful right it's
chaotic nobody has control over anything
and things completely change at some
break break break neck pace but there
are three dimensions that really put
pressure all the things we do one is
just the logic which is hey lots of
detailed information describing
different oncology's across different
sites at what point does it meet makes
sense to generalize at what point does
it become common patterns or across
domains how the way now and lists domain
experts and how do I now recognize that
domain experts don't exist the only one
company that in fact it's decentralized
and distributed so be enough to tap into
that and be able to reason on both the
domain-specific but also the domain
general these are the common sense these
are the basic things on units on basic
understanding of distance like there are
lots of things that I think are
shareable and fundamental well the time
dimension everything changes which it's
just that nobody tells us that they're
changing and and so even coming up with
both the ability to detect the status
updates but also be able to see whether
you can create even big incentives where
they are willing to tell you that things
are changing and so to look at systems
to system integrations and under in the
space you can imagine that the category
and the domain and the scope continues
to expand across domains across facets
across entity so in Bing I'd say that
there are a couple of pivotal points in
which we've shifted that really grew our
horsepower to a tackle some of these all
this three of them the first one is a
shift from batch based conflation to a
streaming based completion right that's
a fundamental shift imagine it's no
longer that hey on Monday of every week
you take all
the data sources you do a big job and
you publish a big blob of a graph is it
correct I hope so but you know that's
but it takes time it's like you know it
used to be a couple of weeks and but the
web doesn't work like that it's not a
it's not a discretized sequence event so
we shifted into a streaming based system
which changes everything the notion of
having an incremental base the ability
to start looking at updates in a
different way ability to now look at the
incremental conflation and evolution and
even reason about correctness in a
different way the second shift we have
is to start to look at going from the
head to the tail right and that requires
us to dramatically scale our ability to
both manage the ontology but also start
to go into deeper site and domain
understanding in an automated way all
right again that's an area where we're
pushing more and more but clearly lots
more to be done and I think the last one
that I think it's notable is our view of
correctness right correctness it's not
like everything out there is correct or
in fact there are different shades of
correctness there are different
confidence factors and yet nobody's
there to be the ultimate arbiter how do
we deal with that how do we now make
sure that inputs and changes that are
proposed our hypothesis that allows us
to reason score understand the
likelihood of churn before it goes into
the rest of the system may be able to
now get that feedback so these are just
examples in which the current system
continuously evolving like we we like to
say the colleague Eugene Eugene gal
who's in the audience who's running the
satori team would say that knowledge is
always a life system it's a live system
like it's not like you build it and it's
done it's a constant constant evolution
so lots of challenges that can imagine
both systems and algorithmic advances
that allows us to now tackle some of
these so that they can continue to grow
and evolve with the complexity of the
web the the second area is something
we've talked about already which is
knowledge can be represented explicitly
or implicitly and we've seen great
advances in great promise in the neural
modeling of information
we've also seen the advances on symbolic
but their pros and cons right at some
point the discretized representation is
probably too big and too gnarly too hard
to manage in the context of now joining
against the intent or context and vice
versa
and so there's a there benefits of both
there benefits of both one is
understandable to humans but really
computationally not efficient when you
start looking at the mirror ad of
understanding the relatedness and all
that stuff and yet all neuro it's
efficient but it's sometimes you're not
quite sure what's happening
so we've taken some efforts you know I
just list out one example but this is
clearly an active area research that we
hope that we'll see some good advances
in breakthroughs we're seeing that need
to have actually both techniques apply
systematically one example is let's say
you do have a neuro system that allows
you to model against some embedding
space and you have a knowledge graph and
the question is how do I now use the
knowledge graph the bootstrap my
understanding and the way you do that is
in order to do this mapping we first
understand the hypothesis that are
available in terms of the questions and
answers in the knowledge graph we apply
that through the system so it urns and
maps it against an embedding space oh
sorry I went too fast maps it against in
a better space so over time you can
imagine that through techniques like
this or similar we can hopefully start
to now bootstrap and connect and
hopefully even do this in a much more
integrated way but this is an active
area research that I encourage all of
you to look at and see what we can do
together
then on the enterprise going back again
on this enthusiasm that people have
around enterprises and their knowledge
but lots of lots of unstructured
information in people's communications
then the documents people right people
don't writing structured facets and
fields and certainly they don't they
write it with different variant degrees
equality and if there's a study from
Gardner that says over 80% of
enterprises knowledge is
and unavailable for broader use and
that's that's a staggering number you
talk to IP you talk to the companies
they're saying you know I don't know
like it's all kind of black box to me
and the data continues to grow so in the
world in which data is growing massively
they're seeing tremendous value but they
can't make sense of it because they're
stored in different ways written in
different formats and not conflated what
do they do and that's a real challenge
but that's also a real opportunity and
so let me give you one example of how
this is coming to bear so about late
last year
and early this year we engage with
publicist which is a advertising agency
they have lots of agencies they acquired
like 1,200 acquisitions they have 200
sub agencies they have 80,000 people
each one you can imagine having their
understanding of clients their
understanding of the work the
advertising campaigns they're deep
understanding of brands their talent
profile so it's lots of information so
in their case what they're saying is
they want to see the benefits of scale
right here's an example of a digital
transformation where a company is really
at the very fundamental level which is
the fact that I have 80,000 and 1200
acquisitions how do I get scale
advantage I'm going to get scale you got
to bring that reinforce and so what we
were working with them is to start to
bring together their understanding of
their talent understanding of their
accounts understanding of the work
they've done and start to create really
disability - no reason map and correlate
right this is something that I'd say
that if you're an online company or a
commerce company you just do this but
for enterprise this is all new stuff
this is all new stuff and in fact it
requires the deeper understanding
appreciation of how do you reason with
knowledge and to get that flying but in
the course of these engagements we also
recognize that enterprise knowledge is
unique it's unique it's got there's only
unique challenges in two dimensions one
is they're they're you know data in
enterprises not readily accessible to
everybody it's not like it's a public
web documents that anybody can read this
is private email right this is documents
that are sensitive this is lean or ACP
documents there
lots of information that you just cannot
even see and enterprises have
obligations both in terms of regulatory
compliance right certain financial data
a certain HR data can't be shared
there's certain encumbrance commitments
if you get data from third parties for
whatever reason you have obligations to
limit its scope of views you have
security considerations different people
have different access rights and you
have privacy with gdpr that ability for
end-users both employees and customers
to now have control and that ability to
influence that data is critical so all
of this is creating a case where in many
cases we're in are quite sure how do you
build an AI model when you can't
reliably see the data that's a real
challenge so within within Microsoft
Office for example we have different
practices we keep out the highest
standard and we in fact enlist the users
in this case Microsoft employees to
contribute portion of their email for us
to build the models but you can imagine
new techniques and new approaches are
needed for us to get beyond this hump
and that is not necessarily the same
algorithms an approach that works in the
web and in public data can work in the
enterprise setting so lots of
innovations around multi-party secure
computations private computations that
are potential here but perhaps the most
challenging is that their access to the
data within an enterprise is of mixed
degrees of quality and completeness
right it's a bootstrapping problem hey
I'm interested in doing all this but the
data may not be clean it has their
variant degrees of quality it may not be
complete in fact in order to bring that
domain expertise it's typically diffused
it's not any one organization has that
depth and certainly not the same the
talent that knows the domain doesn't
necessarily understand the systems so
with that I would say we're at this
stage where might we are seeing this
desire to transform and knowledge is
increasingly this fundamental capability
that is starting to
reshape the way we think about
information and interactions and so I
would just say that imagine
fast forward a couple of years from now
where you're saying imagine you're
living in a knowledge rich world every
person has behind him or her this rich
knowledge graph up there are activities
interest interactions relationships
every object every physical space has
its own knowledge graph that's created
from different organizations for
different purposes and every service has
his own associated knowledge bringing
all that together in some coherent way
where they're multi-party they aren't
working together and yet you need to now
attest and navigate and interact in a
fluid way across is a real opportunity
but it's a real challenge and so with
that these are some of the questions in
domains and and and it is hopefully
there to inspire that I believe we are
heading in a way where we are gonna see
a knowledge ecosystem we're gonna see
knowledge technologies for both the
production and the consumption knowledge
it will require different teams and
different people to work together and
we're still early in this research and
technology innovation wave so with that
let me bring in my colleague consum to
come talk to us about one example of how
we want to push on this process great
thank you
thank you David good morning it is my
pleasure and to be here to talk to you
about knowledge system and AI after all
it was eight years ago in this very
venue Microsoft research faculty summit
in 2010 that we first described our
ambition to teach the machine to acquire
knowledge from the web by itself in
addition in the ensuing years in
addition to the continuing investment
from Microsoft that David has just
described we are glad to see that look
the idea the little idea presented eight
years ago has received industry-wide
adoption including the Google's
knowledge graph efforts two years after
our offical summit and the Baidu's
announcement in siga our 2014 so today
it is my pleasure
to be here to share with you the next
evolution for us to share the resources
we have from the industry research lab
with it that consists of a data set and
open source tools that can facilitate
research with the hope that more of you
can join us to the inner journey to
advance the state as part of analogous
systems and research so let me start
with the data set this is as David
alluded Microsoft academic graph like
the pin knowledge graph it is it is
extra it is built by extracting and
large from the entire web and so we have
the scale to cover the all the scholarly
communications published in the past one
and half centuries so speak speaking of
an ecosystem this is knowledge graph
that every one of you is already on as a
node so is every student that you have
supervised every institution that has
sponsored your work all the journals
that you have cited and the conferences
that have gone you have gone to present
your work so as you see the number is
increasing very is is massive and it's
growing rapidly right so one of the
benefit of sitting on top of being is we
have the broad coverage so as you can
see that we have teach our machine to
cope a young computer science and to
cover more than 200,000 fields and
subfields including medicine art history
and so on this broad coverage turns out
to be very important for research
managers and your provost and Dean's
maybe to understand the impact broader
impacts of our research and for many
decision makers to determine the
investment or research so I hope that
this is give you a some incentive to
take a look at of data but for us you
give us a strong use
and to push the technology to make sure
the data quality is here being
researches ourselves we naturally have
published paper to describe how this
graph is created and what we envision it
can do and the easiest way are to fly
this paper is 200 to remember it is
published in dubbed about 2015 and so
you can just in this system you can just
type 2015 and right there you you can
see all the papers are published in this
air in this in that year and our paper
is actually cutting reg number to other
sexual results so they are choosing
immediately you can notice the first is
the query so by recognizing the
conference as a first class citizen in
the knowledge graph we can we can
actually do more query searching better
search experience by not just keyword
matching the query terms to the title
and I understand that many of many of my
colleagues have been using this feature
when they are rounding the test of time
awards committee are to find our papers
and in their citations for the
particular venue and this - you can do
you can do it with a single query in
this tool and I can also collect a
report for the past two years since I
discovered this new usage
I've been watching it and our ranking
system has been able to predict the test
of time awards winners quite accurately
and that's actually the second thing
that I was likely talked about the
ranking here is actually the full-blown
search ranking and it's not just based
on citation counts as you can see the
the second the third search result is
actually receive more citations than
than us and so but the ranking algorithm
here is actually also estimating the
reputation of the citing parties not
just quietly counted citation so I'll be
more than happy to talk more about it
with you afterwards right so if this
train continues I'm predicting the
w20 25 this paper about a neural
representation of a knowledge system is
likely the winner of the test of time
awards and this paper is that
coincidentally is from my colleague in
MSR a Gentile now for many of you for
speaking of Aegean who has who
unfortunately do have a very common name
and many of you too have the common name
to get your research results
I'll aggregate correctly on a search
engine has been your challenge isn't it
right so let's try it for my colleague
Jen if you try to sit with your favorite
search engine keyword basic search
engine you will see well yes oh they are
quite a few G and hung in the system and
the results are actually intertwined
together but because this system is
sitting on top of a being we were able
to use all sort of knowledge including
your CV and resume is published on the
web and you actually learn how to
disambiguate different authors so for
example when in this system we actually
when you hover over different names in
turn internally at the back end we
actually understand which gentle is
which and not to mention all sorts of
other variation our physics colleagues
like to publish their their their papers
with only first initial and last name
and in many publication the extra apps
are observed the Asian Convention by
putting family first rather than last
and so these are all different
hypotheses we put it here as I alluded
yes you already seen you can just just
hover over it in this case this is our
colleague our G and what I want and just
a one additional click voila all his
work is aggregate correctly and showing
here so this is I hope this is giving
you a quick understanding about what the
knowledge system can help us and how you
can enrich the experience we have and so
let's now switch back out you
the PowerPoint so here's so if you're
interested by this useful I'm interested
these are these are the resources we're
making freely available to everyone the
first one is the graph the data set is
available through Azure we again really
available to everyone and there's a also
and in the same folder you will fight a
lot of open source tools they hopefully
connects with you jump start all these
operations to deal with large data set
and chronology systems we encourage you
to take a look and as you see we have
already more than 100 system 21 and 27
systems that are already published based
on this data set I invite you to take a
look and tell us what you can build more
information is that URL or a k-8 ms/ms
are a cat with that thank you for your
attention
and let me welcome take it back alright
thank you let me wrap it up if you roll
back at the beginning what we're seeing
is this emergence of an appreciation for
knowledge knowledge is gonna push the
limits of systems in AI but it has a
transformative effect in the way we
think about products and we think about
companies and this is also a rich area
where we're still at the forefront of
that technology race and that technology
push and with that I want to really
thank all of you for your attention your
participation in the faculty summit I'm
excited the Microsoft is such a strong
advocate for academia and for research
and we are looking forward to seeing
amazing things from all of you and from
our collaboration so thank you
[Applause]
you